embrassé
[Musique]
que toi tu ne pensais
si bien écoute la chanson tes citoyens
[Musique]
dépêche-toi on passe là
tu m'as désobéi tu t'es aventuré à la
surface un homme allait se noyer
cette obsession pour les humains doit
cesser c'est envie d'en savoir davantage
sur eux
reviens
je peux t'aider tu ne pourras pas vivre
dans ce monde à moins de devenir humaine
mais est-ce possible
que pour
ça
tu as quelque chose de changé mais je
saurais pas dire quoi je vois pas c'est
très bizarre elle a des jambes tu ne
vois pas
je ne sais pas pourquoi je t'aime mais
je suis prête à t'aimer
quand prince la chance
la vie commence
[Musique]
pourtant
c'est un humain il n'est pas de notre
monde
[Musique]